we caught your show in kind of an odd
location i kind of peeked around the
corner they can't run any of it or i
mean they can't i couldn't i wasn't
allowed to shoot any oh okay good
i would have to beat probably three
quarters of your show out because you
were a dirty daddy i can be thank you
thanks for that plug too
and that book explains why i'm like this
but it does and you know what i didn't
get through it yet i do have it in my
bag
it's my would you like to sit down and
dictate it to me that's my big move
but i from what i have read it's very
revealing and incredibly honest that was
what i wanted to be i mean we had a lot
of death in our family and a lot of
humor and a lot of irreverent comedy
came out of it so it kind of
that's what warped me into being
this i don't i don't even know how this
happens i mean i came out today and
introduced snoop dogg which was i heard
nice are you a fan yeah i've known them
a while we've we've been i've run around
them for 15 years or something i've
known them and been things
last week i was in um ottawa at the
blues fest and he was performing
i just see him i've been on the tonight
show with him and conan and all that you
know showbiz so beautiful oh yeah but he
went when i show up in a room nobody
knows ahead of time but when he shows up
you can feel the waft of him
you know there's an afterglow yes yes
and i understand by your show you don't
partake
i don't like i mean just now you can
hear i lost my voice a little bit
because that happens in a thing when you
do your thing
and i'm not a smoker
in my twenties i did in my early
twenties but then i
i'm just not that guy i get i get heady
so yeah
well and i would think it would be hard
to remember
where you're gonna go next like i would
end up probably somewhere over on this
mountain over here exactly
i could i think with stand-up comedy
it's probably
something that could work against you
i can't do anything before i work at all
i mean i could take like some caffeine
or something you know it was funny years
ago somebody asked me to be a partner on
a company and i said no it's not good
it'll amp up people's hearts and it was
red bull and i said no and they offered
they asked me to and now i have it
before the show i'll have one if i'm
wanting one and they're not great for
you but i could have
it would be
incredibly wealthy i'd still be in the
tent you would still be doing well you
would still be doing i'd still be doing
this is it because it's your ultimate
passion no it's just one of the things i
love i'm working on um
getting a movie directed right now that
i've been working on for a tasty for
three years and i mean it took a year
off to write the book um
and i love acting and stuff there's
people intense they're they're laying in
there right there i know they're right
there
yeah they're they're pretty uh there's a
bunch of dudes over there there's total
dude talk actually you should listen
it's probably some good fodder for your
next act i smell bong water
there's broken bongs out there
definitely a lot of broken bongs around
here have you been covering this whole
thing have you been around i arrived
today and i've been kind of cruising
around haven't haven't had a chance to
talk with too too many people but got a
taste of it it's nice comedy is a nice
addition to a festival like this that's
not something you always see no and i
really love it i did bonnaroo a couple
years ago and i brought stamos out at
the end of my little song they loved
that quite a bit and that was a great
comedy audience too really smart
comedians like david cross and just
people that i really like and here it's
really good comedians i mean it's
if i can remember everybody tom green's
on lisa lampanelli
um
i can't remember everybody that's good
those are two good names natasha legero
no um no full house cameos here though
i'm a little disappointed oh actually
john is uh john shot a yogurt commercial
yesterday and then tomorrow today flew
to new york because he's got a movie
opening so he's going to new york to do
all of his promotion on monday
everyone has good excuses but you guys
are all
i mean you have these stories and a lot
of these stories aren't from the 90s
they're from you know last week
you're still as tight as you were back
in the day it's upsetting it's it's it
keeps us young and it makes me feel like
it wasn't i don't like disingenuous
relationships in my life so it's uh i i
didn't i didn't have any i mean i've had
some but i didn't have any with that
show i saw lori last night actually in a
restaurant and um i was at dave's
wedding as people know because people
people people knows
and uh and i just i'm very close with
john and dave and it's really lovely
there's been so much talk over the last
especially the last year i don't know
why about reunions full house reunions
the teasing commercials and
are you down for it would you do it
absolutely not i mean well it's
instagrams they keep saying it i mean
but it's not
it's not going to happen because you
need to have everybody and it's not it's
just not it would have to be written in
a way that was so smart and
not like the brady movie where they all
were wigs and it wasn't them
but everybody in the cast except myself
it looks really good but i mean i don't
think it was really done right and
but i don't you know it's not going to
happen we just love being together and
separately i have different
relationships with everybody so it's
nice so actually i've seen one of your
shows before this wasn't my first which
one were you at i was at the orpheum in
vancouver no no sorry pardon me river
rock in vancouver oh that's fun and it
was fun and you were hilarious and dirty
and wonderful thank you and i had i kept
thinking during your set
how did you make it through eight
seasons without
revealing that to the young children
around you and to the audience
something was happening i've talked to
everybody about it i mean at the end of
the beginning of the show candace was
nine and ashley mary kate were nine
months so that's how the show started so
they knew something funny and
off was going on but they and i didn't
curse i didn't do blue words i didn't
even use blue words in my stand up much
i just said weird stuff always always
and
i d i did an hbo special waffle house in
america's funniest home videos were both
on and they were in the top ten and i
did do an hbs before i cursed a bunch so
i mean
it has been my
whatever that gene is here but i never
cursed but i said weird stuff and i
would just i mean in the book
dirty daddy plugged my book
but it it tells a chapter of how it
happened i mean kind of how
we did just stupid stuff and it was
really fun we were acting like little
kids it was more little kids than
dirty men
we acted really
incredibly immature well and by the
sounds of it you still do we do yes yeah
and we've done some pretty there's
something really satisfying about about
that having watched the show right and
it's being so squeaky clean and then
knowing that you're all just a bunch of
dirty dudes we're not dirty dave's not
dirty well he's funnier than me and in
filthy way okay funny silly yeah silly i
think is what it is i don't even think
i'm that dirty but that's me i mean what
i don't i don't you ever watched your
own show have you ever watched
i mean
it's a little dirty but my intention is
not my intention is silly and it's like
nintendo is a 14 year old boy's
mentality it's not really i'd like to be
more involved and the book had more of
an adult person being reflective but you
couldn't play a music festival and come
out and be reflective about what life's
about
you could if you were a great stand-up
but this isn't the venue
for that kind of comedy i don't think
especially when you can barely see the
audience
yeah it was really fun and the sun was
it's really beautiful yeah do you do you
feel inspired when you're in a place
like this and you're you know surrounded
by all this majesty and beauty yep as
what i was saying as soon as i got here
but then also as soon as i got here i
was like i just took a quick break and
then i
introduced snoop dogg which is a pretty
cool experience
and that was for the giant thing over
there and then i ran right over here and
did this show and i go home and go to
work next week so it's like are you
gonna stick around and see some live
action i am gonna stay a little bit i'm
gonna watch lisa lampanelli in a few
minutes and then any what about bands
anybody that you're dying i don't know i
don't know the schedule i've got to look
at it because i don't think you can just
kind of wander around bob they take me
in a car yeah i really am a big bird in
a suit
i know
at least they stopped calling me danny
tanner at least they go bob
that's true you've made it past that
congratulations become my own name yes
you have wow that's quite a feat
thank you
congratulations you're always fun to
watch thank you
you